l'actrice et écouteront connu pour avoir
joué le commissaire mado dans la série
qui cartonne y voilà à payer elle a
répondu aux tweets qui compare la
vaccination obligatoire au viol les six
a donc accusé véronique genest d'avoir
un comportement raciste et radicale
surtout sur le tournage de julie lescaut
un comportement qui aurait motivé sa
décision de quitter la série à lire se
polir lire ce tweet ce matin ce n'est
pas une attaqué en diffamation comptoir
et impasses sanitaires pour ou contre
ici n'est pas le débat un viol et non
seulement d'une bêtise intellectuelle
mais également le reflet d'une manque
d'empathie 23 données de discernement
qui revient régulièrement dans tes
propos mais j'espère voilà et donc elle
à elle à l avenir elle a juste pas le
droit de dire que ce que c'est les
parties de la série l avouez le vous
résiste à vous amuser dans le droit-fil
attaque en diffamation j'ai appelé jean
charles chagachbanian tout à l'heure et
je lui dis je suis dit que je recherche
moi je suis bien cas du genre qu'est
jaugeant le point 6 c'était quelqu'un
qui joue avec moi pendant d'accord que
plus de deux saisons de julie avec qui
j'ai passé des moments formidables
guillaume gabriel maquilleuse et tout et
tout le monde staff gésir leslie compte
abandonner d'autres blessés et ont dû
d'abord et non radicale et raciste moi
et moi même je me dis ah bon j'ai eu un
nom des propos mais mais franchement si
quelqu'un peut trouver un propos raciste
dans tout ce que je dis je veux dire je
veux bien l'admettre mais moi là je vais
attaquer attaquer en diffamation parce
qu'on ne peut pas dire des choses comme
ça qui sont appris par la presse et ça
je ne peux pas laisser dire non nous
aurons deux pôles pas est ce que vous
savez de quoi elle parle véronique ou
peu d'eau n'ont aucune idée mais aucune
idée jean st se rappelait même panel
mais bon elle est bon c'est moi qui
l'ait choisi un portrait dès jeudi j'ai
été adorable laquelle on a passé de très
bons moments je n'ai jamais tenus enfin
je veux dire j'étais dans une mauvaise
période de ma vie parce que j'avais des
problèmes familiaux à cause de gens
autour de quelqu'un de très proche qui
était très malade donc c'était une
période difficile de deux personnes très
proches de moi qui était très malade qui
avait les vernis j'ai commencé à grossir
c'est une période très dure de ma vie à
assumer pour moi mais j'allais bosser et
je bossais et les seuls souvenirs que
jean charles en a il m'a rappelé et il
me le rappelait un crachin j'étais au
téléphone en arrivant ici ce mot mais
juste et interpeller j'ai pas compris et
c'était de me dire il n'a que des
souvenirs de rigolade et qu'une envie
c'est qu'on recommence à travailler
ensemble moi je suis énervé parce que
j'en peux plus que non la liberté
d'expression aujourd'hui on dise des
gens dire qu'on laisse dire des gens
n'importe quoi et des choses dangereuses
je pense que vous ne connaissez rien à
faire de racisme je n'ai pas entendu ce
qui s'est passé depuis en espagne et
pardon là j'ai pas remplacés
vous ne connaissez rien à la religion
aux religions je pense vous ne
connaissez rien à la gt r je pense vous
ne connaissez rien vous n'êtes pas
médecin mais très saillant d'axa et vous
y arrivez mais vous traitez les gens
vous dites par exemple à des gens qui ne
peuvent pas avoir d'enfant vous l'avez
acheté et donc
pour exister aujourd'hui bon d'inviter
sur des sujets dangereux dont vous les
connaissez
qui sont
très sèches et rien ne leur vire je dis
pas ça
vous est péremptoire sur le ml palmarès
à un vol et viol pardon sur sur le bâti
vous n'y connaissez rien amené de femmes
et sa régie rassembler quand vous dit
quelque chose c'est par dallas encore
sépare de la m mais je ne voyais pas
d'accord vous avez droite pape diop et
guillaume genton mais est ce que dit on
nique sur la liberté d'expression c'est
vrai moi ce qui m'étonne dans cette
affaire on n'était pas là pour vérifier
s'il avait eu des propos racistes ou pas
évidemment que c'est mal d'être raciste
mais c'est que là elle tient un propos
forts elle donne son opinion a la droit
de le faire et que pour la faire taire
en fait on dit en gros seins elle est
folle elle est folle elle a un avis
contre le coc vite façon à l'épaule et
raciste elle pense que le vaccin c'est
un job de toute façon elle n'aime pas
l'islam mais quel rapport en fait on a
le droit de les laisser dire ce qu'elle
dit non non
on dira alors c'est la pensée unique on
a droit de rien dire alors de ne pas
être content de dette contre le vaccin
on lui reproche d'avoir d'abord comparer
ça à un viol
ma vie mais maintenant je connais de ma
vie je savais toi tu connais si c'est
pas la vôtre madame on en reparle de la
ca par tout le monde et vous mettez vos
crampons sur twitter va vous parler à
dont cheikh samba yvonne à 10h09 et ans
et demi pour havas le droit de juger ce
que je dis mais qu'est ce que vous
connaissez de la vie des autres pour
dire justement qu'un ange les bonduois
lagarde le pauvre non j'ai dit
simplement que ça peut arriver